David F. Sandberg [a.k.a. Ponysmasher on Youtube] and Filmmaker: It was only always my dream to make
movies and it was always my dream to be
a Hollywood director. Erik Bork, Screenwriter/Author: I pursued being a
film major in my undergraduate in Ohio
which is my home state and got a
four-year degree BFA and motion picture
production which of course guarantees
you a job in the industry immediately
when you show up with that. Rhys Thomas, Writer/Director: Where I grew
up was about as far from the film
industry as as could be, well no as can
be, I'm sure I could have grown up in
Siberia too but I grew up in a small
village in South Wales and really had
zero idea of you know how you might
penetrate the film industry or
television. Todd Berger, Writer/Director: I was you know living in
Austin I was delivering pizza I was
gonna move to Chicago and do Second City
and then you go to New York because you
know I grew up thinking like LA like
Hollywood like sell out? What am I gonna
sell out? Corey Mantel, Screenwriter/Instructor: Maybe she was thinking do I
really want to put my career on the line
with this guy like I was a nobody I was
in film school I had I was a was like 23
and green as they came. Dr. Ken Atchity, Author/Producer: And I realized
that I wasn't 18 years old in the
mailroom at William Morris and I wasn't
you know infinitely wealthy and I didn't
have relatives in the film business
those are like the three main ways to
get into the business normally. Markus Redmond, Screenwriter/Actor/Director: What am i
doing I'm sitting here and staring at a
phone that doesn't ring you know phone's
not going anywhere I'm not going
anywhere I could be sitting here a year
from now and me and my phone can be
hanging out together or I can be sitting
here here from now me and my phone could
be hanging out with the script that I
wrote. Danny Strong, Screenwriter/Producer: Would I do this for the rest of my
life if I got nothing in return and I
thought yeah I would. Robin Riker, Actress/Author: I was crushed
I mean it it was the hardest I couldn't
believe that this is what had happened
again in this year
and I literally went on my face on the
rug and I just wept and wept and wept.
Lakeith Stanfield: And I missed a lot of auditions cuz I
couldn't make it but uh you know and
that that was a hard time cuz I
hated missing them I rather get rejected
and then to miss it. Alex Sol, Actor: If there is a moment
in
where you you you feel some kind of
unbelievable good fortune or a dream
come true I guess would be the word
it was only always my dream to make
movies and it was always my dream to be
a Hollywood director but that was kind
of like a secret because I'm you know
I'm from Sweden and it's like the other
side of the world like I don't have any
like family members who are in show biz
or anything like that so I might like
you can say to friends and family like
yeah I'm gonna be a hold of director cuz
people are gonna be like yeah sure like
I'm gonna be the king of Spain whatever
you know but that was always the goal
and then it's been you know a lot of
times that goal has felt really far away
and I've been very depressed and it felt
like well this is never gonna happen of
course but that was always the goal like
that was what I wanted to do with my
life so in a way it's been you know you
can't say that it's been expected but
it's always been the goal so it's always
been like yeah that's what I really want
so so it's more of like you know the
feeling is not that surprised
well it is a feeling of surprise that
wow it actually happened what I want you
know my dream actually came true but the
dream has always been there if that
makes sense I think video store was my
first job which was sort of under the
table not really official but but it was
it was kinda cool I loved it because
yeah I had access to movies I could rent
all these free movies and sometimes you
get screeners so you could see movies
before they came out on video and things
like that but I've never been much of a
people person
what so I mean it's a you know you have
to talk to people a lot which is that
was the downside of it about all the
movies that was the great part and then
I worked a little bit in like grocery
stores and things like that and I hated
that even more because that's you know
the downsides of working in a video
store but without the movies so and then
I was unemployed for quite a while it's
really depressed I was you know still
living with my mom in my 20s and
eventually yeah I started making
animation because I've always wanted to
make movies I was making movies with
friends but then as we started getting
older you know your friends are getting
jobs and lives and suddenly it's like
there's not as much time
- and willingness to make little dumb
shorts so that's when I started doing
animation because it was something I
could do all by myself I didn't have to
rely on other people's schedules or
money or whatever it was just like I've
always liked drawing so I could do that
on my computer all by myself I'll just
record the voices and didn't even need
an expensive camera for it
and I was lucky in that this was in 2005
2006 when YouTube was a new thing so you
know I signed up to that
didn't really know what it was but it's
like okay I can upload videos here and I
uploaded a little animated short I made
and got a really good response like
people really seem to like it so was i
well this is great so I made another one
one that was a little bit more ambitious
than the first one the first one was
almost like a slideshow I mean I
hesitate to call it animation because it
was it's an actual slideshow but then
the second one I got more ambitious with
and I made this story that was very
personal about sort of the the thoughts
in your head that put you down and like
tell you that you're shit and you know
basically an angel and the devil on your
shoulder and that one really took off on
line got all these views and then really
went viral but it was in Swedish so it
didn't go outside of Scandinavia but
like Norway Denmark and people it's
Finland and that got me a lot of
attention I got like to go on TV and
like what's it like to have a viral hit
and it also led me led to me getting
some jobs like companies or like we want
to make a little funny video about our
product or whatever and we loved your
funny video can you do something for us
and I would do that and often it's kind
of fun because the shorts I made were
very crude I think they had a lot of bad
language and like being penises and and
things like that and of course when
companies want to do something it's like
yeah we want that but not that you know
so you kind of have to do yeah it's
something that's not as fun but now
was actually getting some money getting
paid which was great and so I could move
out and didn't have to live with my mom
anymore and this also led to me meeting
my wife I mean that we actually dated
when we were 11 Oh
she was into acting I was already into
making movies and then when this short
went viral she saw it and you know we
dated when we were 11 then had a 14-year
break and she saw this movie and was
like recognized my voice and contacted
me to reconnect and we did and got back
together and now you know when we now
were dating you know she was an actress
you know I had a video camera it's like
oh we can make things together and we
tried getting money from the Swedish
Film Institute because in Sweden you
know you apply for grants from the Film
Institute for your short or even for
your features that's basically how all
movies are made there but we didn't have
any look because they weren't as
interested in sort of the John Rose
stuff that we wanted to do and I think
I've always had sort of four always had
sort of a commercial bent for movies
like that's kind of my taste you know
American fun popcorn movies and things
like that in Sweden especially when you
have that grant based system and it's
taxpayer money and they have to be
really responsible what they do with
that money it often goes to films that
are more sort of important and take up
sort of issues with society and things
like that nothing wrong with that I I
mean it's led to some great movies but
yeah it didn't really work out for us so
we were turned down and then we felt
like well screw it I mean you're an
actress I have a camera we let's just do
something you know we don't need money
we can do a little shorts ourselves so
we did a little short called chem closer
that was a horror short about like a
phone that sees the future I put that up
on my youtube channel that now had a few
thousand followers from my animated work
and they were kind of surprised a lot of
the followers because they expected sort
of humorous animated things and how son
leads this terrifying little horror
short
but people still seem to like it even
though they were surprised and we really
enjoyed doing it and then we saw this
there was an online contest by these
horror collective in the UK called
bloody cuts like make a under three
minute horror film and you can win
prizes and things so we were like well
that's what we're doing now we just did
camp closer let's do something for this
and that's when we did lights out again
just me and looked in our apartment
trying to like figure out okay what can
we do that's scary and we're like you
know I think everyone's I had that
feeling of you know in our house it was
a coat rack that you walk out in the
middle of the night like ooh looks like
someone standing there and you turn on
the light so it's nothing there and
that's sort of how it you know playing
around with the light give us this idea
of okay there's there's something that
actually is there every time you turn
off the lights so we did that uploaded
it to the contest and then we found out
that we didn't win the contest but then
a little while later they also had
secondary prizes so I won Best Director
looks like oh that's awesome
but we didn't think that anything else
would happen with that we were like oh
you know fun let's make more movies but
then a few months after that this was in
March 2014
I saw him ready that someone had linked
to our short and it's like oh that's
awesome
I show look tie and then I go in to see
the stats and it was like 17,000 years
since I called it's so much that's
awesome
and then just minutes later it was like
70,000 views and then it was up over a
hundred and forty thousand views and it
just kept going and going it's like
what's happening but I think that I mean
it was just two and a half minutes short
and there's no dialogue in it I think
that really helped it to spread I mean
partly because you know people don't
have an attention span anymore so it's
like if they see it's only two and a
half minutes I can watch that and
because there's no dialogue it can
spread everywhere so we've really sort
of lucked into something that was really
nuna versal
and yeah I was just a few days after
that I actually said to look that you
know I've heard of people getting
representation in Hollywood from Shores
like for managers and agents and things
like that and like the day after I said
that I woke up to an email from a
management firm here in Hall and I
showed love those like I told you it's
like it's starting and then it was just
like open the floodgates because we got
emails from agents and managers and
producers and studios and like sometimes
actors and then people live as well a
makeup artist and all these things like
what is this and you know these managers
and agents that want to represent us and
you know I had to get like an IMDB Pro
account just to find out who these
people are and eventually I you know I
picked a manager who could then help us
navigate this whole thing we're getting
an agent and then who can we trust with
producers and all of that and yeah we've
this producer the Lawrence Gray seemed
really good and he was really into it
you know cuz a lot of them were just
wanted to know who we were and what our
plans were you know and you don't know
like they didn't explicitly say we want
to make this movie or we want to
represent you so and I kind of need that
because I'm Swedish and kind of
introverted like I'm not good with sort
of interpreting subtle signs like so so
I went with like the producers like yes
I want to make this movie we should make
this movie boom all right let's go we
went with with Lawrence Gray who and you
know it was kind of a weird situation
because once this happened it was about
a year before the movie happened which
is actually pretty quick but it feels
strange in that situation to sort of
wait for all of these things and not
knowing if it's real if it's actually
going to happen or not because during
this year it was you know signing with a
management firm and an agency and all of
that and then finding a writer working
with the writer to develop a script and
making a deal for all this with you know
getting a
lawyer and all that so during this year
left and I we didn't know if this was
actually real or if it was all bullshit
so we were like well we can't stop going
so we kept making shorts um you know
around our house where we could come up
with little new ideas we made one in the
attic one of the basement and just try
and come up with new stuff and you know
for each of these shorts I would make
these a little behind the scenes videos
that was that turned out to be very
appreciated by people who saw this like
other up-and-coming filmmakers and it
was something I did just because I loved
that's what I wanted to see I wanted to
see you know I've always loved seeing
behind the scenes and making of x' and
all these because you know just to learn
as much as possible and see what it's
like on a film set and how do you create
these things and all that so we just
kept doing that and we even had this
idea that we would make a feature just
her and I if this didn't pan out but
then in March something like that of
2015 they basically saw yeah movies is
happening we need you here like next
week or whatever so look uh basically
had to quit her job because you were
working in a group home you know I was a
freelance animator so I didn't have
anything steady going so we basically
you know locked our apartment got on a
plane and this was you've paid for about
the studio because we were broke like
when we first got a manager you know
they were like can you get out here
because we want you to meet all these
people and go like on this you know tour
of Hollywood's like oh hey this is this
guy and whatever but we didn't have any
money so it's like yeah we can't do that
but then they pay for us to have to fly
out here and yeah it was very strange we
we had to find a place to live here and
it's everything is super expensive in LA
but we found on it and Airbnb this half
a garage in Burbank it was sort of part
of into - so this mother and her
daughter were our neighbors in this
garage it was like I mean for us
was like two and a half grand or
something my mother for us that is
insane yeah I I mean it was a pretty
nice garage I mean it wasn't bad or
anything but it was quite a shock to
find out how expensive it was and we
still didn't have any money and when we
got over here you have a studio paid for
the flight over and everything and they
were gonna pay for living expenses but
not until it was greenlit and it wasn't
actually greenlit until quite late so we
had to I mean first of all we borrowed
from everyone we knew back home in
Sweden and then that money went out it's
like I do what we do now so we had to
borrow from the producer and there like
a manager and it was kind of dicey
because it was like was this doesn't
happen we're in deep shit because we're
like all borrowed out when it comes to
money but then thankfully it did happen
in the movie but yeah it was all pretty
crazy because I had never been on a
movie set before so the first time I
actually stepped foot on a real movie
set it was asked the director oh it's
pretty crazy I mean especially because I
mean everyone there had more experience
than me and every assistant your PA and
like they've all done worked on real
movies and I you know and and part of me
think you know I think they kind of
thought I was more experienced than I
was and you know I wasn't gonna correct
them it's a psychiatric
one want me to make your movie oh well
but you know they would ask me of oh do
you have a DP you usually work with or
an editor or a storyboard artist and it
was just know I've done all these things
myself because I've had to you know
actually the year before it went viral
was the first time we were in LA because
we we had I made a little animated
documentary that it got into a film
festival in San Jose and so we got a
little bit of money from the Swedish
Film Institute to actually go to that
Film Festival and then was like well
let's go to LA as well and we have we
the the producer who we worked with to
make that whole animated documentary he
was like well let's go pitch the studios
in Hollywood and it's like what are you
insane like well what do you mean pitch
the studios have been Hollywood like how
are we going to get in or
we're gonna do but he actually he was
like no my brother actually works at Fox
in Sweden so he can probably get us into
Fox in LA I was like okay and it was
like all right let's pitch like a horror
movie or something I actually wrote a
little horror movie and which was my
first like script in English and
everything and we actually got to go
there and and pitch this thing we had to
sign all these disclaimers because we
weren't represent or anything and you
know it was an interesting experience
but it was clearly just like oh he's a
friend of him just you know just just
listen to it you know I mean nothing
came of it or anything but it was still
a cool experience like yeah got to walk
on the Fox lot you know and actually sit
there and talk to movies so yeah we've
been here before but and even got into a
studio but but that was it it was in
March I I mean at the time it was like
four million I remember that I mean it
landed on like 10 million or something
or 11 million but I mean then it's it's
it's kept going and because other people
have uploaded as well and we didn't like
be like oh we they have to take that
down that's our movie or whatever I mean
it's like they didn't change anything of
just like yeah upload we just want
people to see it you know so I saw an
upload on Facebook I don't trust
Facebook's number though because it was
like what was that like 70 80 90 million
or something I was like I don't know
what Facebook does but I yeah sure but a
lot of people seem to have seen it yes
and the one the link that was put on
reddit was at Vimeo or YouTube that was
Vimeo actually so they then went viral
on Vimeo first which seems you know kind
of unique in a way because it seems that
it's mostly YouTube but then since it
was on YouTube as well that exploded too
but it started on on Vimeo I just got
out of high school trying to figure out
what I want to do
and what kind of knew what I wanted to
do I knew I wanted to act in some
capacity so I started really just
googling acting schools acting stuff
anything that encompassed acting trying
to find a sort of channel in and so I
just googled everything and pages and
pages of things popped up and I just
filled everything out and then
eventually you know people started
answering and a lot of those were scams
and things that I would ultimately end
up wasting my time on and so I ended up
going back and forth from LA to
Victorville scrambling up changing one
time it was a school for modeling and
career center modeling careers and so
they I just get up on the runway tell us
to walk the runway and taught us all the
names of the brands and fin de prata all
these different things that would be of
no use to me really but at the time I
realized every other week they had
agents come in for the people that went
in to aspire to get into acting so I
wanted to get in front of these agents
and when one of those agents came
through I said I want to go in this is
audition day was like every Thursday or
something like that and they said well
do you have anything prepared I said yes
I didn't went in anyway and I just did
the first thing that came to my mind
which was basically just to jump up up
up woman chair be like totally and do
some random stuff and the guy saw
something in me that he liked and he
signed me to his commercial agency from
there I began to do auditions and fail
and learn what it meant to be rejected
but be in the room and sort of build my
comfortability over time so it would
prove to be a very important chapter
although at the time I just thought it
was like I was wasting my time but I
proved to be very important once I got
out there really started auditioning I
felt comfortable because I had been
rejected and I've been through all of it
already so there's nothing left to fear
so yeah that was what came of the
internet and I understand you didn't
have a car while you were in Victorville
no and I from what I know I don't think
the bus really runs does it run
no there's a train that goes you got
though some change and take the train
okay but that's quite and that's a fit
that sounds like it's several stops so
how are you going on auditions and or or
or even to this modeling class school
and then coming back and that sounds
like a lot half of it was just trying to
hustle up money to get down and get up
on the train and some of it was my
parents they were helping me every now
and again take me whenever you know
whatever my bit my bugging them sort of
hit it's pretty like fine again for what
because when you're auditioning you
begin you don't realize how much
rejections involved in it so you get
rejected twenty thirty times you're like
what am I still doing this for obviously
it's not gonna work and it was so much
work for us to get down there that they
were just like this is becoming more of
an expense than anything and so I had to
figure out ways to get them to get down
there on my own after a while and I
missed a lot of auditions because I
couldn't make it but uh you know and
that sucked that was a hard time cuz I
hated missing them I rather get rejected
and then to miss it you know now there's
probably there was probably nine hundred
pages on Google probably nine million
now so there's much more to weed from
much more opportunity to get caught up
in different things I would just say I
would say stay in school stay diligent
go through high school go through
college and try to look through
opportunities after having sort of
learned all you can learn and situate
yourself and be comfortable before you
get into acting know that you're doing
there's something else that you could be
doing you know you have a back-up plan
because it's a very difficult tough game
to get into and and it's tough to
maintain even once you're in so it's not
like once just because you booked
something means you're gonna be working
forever
so you have to always keep that hustle
up and continue to look for new avenues
and know that if this doesn't work I got
something else in the back if that don't
worry I got something else have other
alternatives as well and don't focus all
your energy on acting would be one thing
everybody's got their of a particular
route but the thing I think is important
to be an actor is always keep an open
mind always be willing to learn and
don't reach a point where you feel like
I've learned enough and now I don't need
to know anything else because as you
know your talent will take you so far
but you need to be constantly trying to
develop
skills and learning how to access these
characters and analyze these stories and
tell them in the most authentic light
and while your talent will take you a
long way and will take you to the high
since you want to go because there's a
cap a moment where you're like well this
is this is just my talent so you need to
constantly stretch yourself travel meet
new people engage in new experiences
fearlessly and sort of download that
information into sort of creating what
you want to create every role is
different so what may work for one role
may not work for another and vice versa
sometimes your talent would be great for
a certain role and then for another role
you have to reach outside the sort of
boundaries of your natural talent in
order to tap into it those are things
that I find the most rewarding and the
most difficult and they caused me to
have to get studious and learn all these
things you know and get into these
different life styles and understanding
so always keep an open mind and I think
you can explore and do whatever you need
to do and realize remember this game is
not a competition it seems like a
competition but it's not the only person
you're a competition with is yourself
and if you think you can't do a certain
thing you can't if you think you can you
can't just got pushes up characters are
realizations from people's imaginations
so naturally some are going to fit with
your imagination and some are and some
are based off of real people in our
accurate depictions and some are so you
have to use discernment and figure out
what speaks to you what's real to you
and everything is not going to be I
think when you first start acting you're
gonna take anything that comes at you
can juggle work that's understandable
that's what I did that's what I think
most actors did when they first started
out because you need to work it is a job
but at the same time once you start to
develop your craft and you can sort of
weed out what speaks to you and what's
important because it's also important to
do things that correlate with your
frequency that go with how you're
attempting to move because if it doesn't
you're portraying something that isn't
genuine and then your performance is
good people are going to see and be like
this something that isn't genuine about
that so just make sure it connects to
you this is why it's important I think
to expand your horizons and awareness so
way more things have the ability to sort
of click with you because the the broad
the more broaden your horizon is the
more chance
yeah I know what that is rather than
living in a sort of vacuum and then
something coming into your awareness you
- that's true for and I don't know what
that is and never judge the characters
and that was like 20 years ago is when I
made this movie kissing Jessica Stein
and I think it was just there are all
kinds of watershed moments that you have
when you look back at a career and and
sometimes you obviously it's easier to
look back at them and as opposed to when
they're happening that year was
monumental simply because I was doing
camera assisting and I was sort of going
back and forth between shooting and
assisting and I made a real effort that
year to stop doing any assisting and
really cut that tie off and just hanging
the wind with whatever I could get my
hands on and it was just it was tough
going cuz it's early in your career and
you you interview for a lot of stuff but
you don't necessarily get it and kissing
Jessica Stein was near the end of the
year and I remember just thinking wow
that was a tough year it was like a year
of struggle and yet that movie then
served to be at the time was like the
first movie of mine that sort of went to
festivals and made some money and gave
me a profile that allowed me to get
Garden State and Garden State then
allowed me to get you know Dukes of
Hazzard which allowed me to get studio
movies like Dan in real life or you know
or hangover and those kind of things so
each of those things ends up serving as
a stepping stone to the next thing so
you know I've had successes with movies
where like the hangover franchise
obviously gave a profile to me and and
Todd and allowed us to make more movies
and gave me some other opportunities but
I think between Godzilla this year and
Joker both being released in the in the
same year and being not necessarily
comedies or in that genre it's felt like
a a really positive year because I've
just been able to sort of show a little
different gear of myself
photographically and and and just show
muscles that I think other people hadn't
necessary to see things that I've always
wanted to experience which hopefully
will lead to future
projects that will continue to show that
side of myself and allow me to do stuff
that's challenging but also a little bit
artistic as well every movie I ever do I
literally try to say this has to be the
best thing I've ever done every movie
and and so I always set out for that to
be the goal and certainly was the you
know one of the last movies I've done so
so I feel like it's just some extent I
accomplished that for myself what's the
the biggest lesson I took from joke or
making Joker that I would pass on to
filmmakers I think that there's two
things I think one to to really push
yourself and take chances and to just
not take the conservative route so I
think one I can't the movie very simple
in a lot of ways but every day and every
every time we set to do a scene I just
made a conscious effort to like not hold
back and to you know it's easy you take
some risks when you're young and then
you get opportunities in which the
movies get bigger and sometimes you're
under time constraints in which you have
to go back to like a thing you've done
before in a way that can be somewhat
repetitive but also conservative and I
think if you can find opportunities to
to just be as risky as you can be and to
take chances
I think the payoff will be great and I
think that's something I take away for
sure and also when you you know when you
think about what yeah it also will the
movie also was an experience for me
where I have a lot of conversations
between me Todd and Joaquin about which
direction we should go sometimes it was
like photographically sometimes was with
the character sometimes it was with the
story and because I've worked with Todd
six times I was involved in some of
those more intimately than perhaps some
cinematographers would be and I think
what I came across was was sometimes I
was right in my opinion
and sometimes I was wrong same thing
with Todd and Joaquin there were some
times right and so I think between the
three of us I recognize that all those
conversations and sometimes there were
arguments and sometimes they were heated
I recognized that like you're gonna be
right sometimes and you're not gonna be
right sometimes and so it's really
important to have a point of view and
fight for that point of view but also
recognize that that you may not be right
and that the and that that that's always
a no and and so just don't be so
arrogant or self just like don't don't
don't feel that that if you're shot down
in your opinion or whatever direction
you think that suddenly it's not the
right thing for the movie because it may
well be and and and you just can't see
it yet so I think it was like just a
little bit of an experience to recognize
that you know that there are a lot of
different choices you can make in a
movie and and the collaboration I think
is the most important thing and that
each opinion has its own has really
valid sort of pros and cons you know I
had an idea for a movie and I pitched it
to my agent and she goes out I think
this is great let's take it up to the
marketplace and then she said let's make
a list of our dream places that we want
to sell it so she goes if you could sell
anyone who would it be
and it was so heavy I thought like oh
yeah who would I sell it to and I said
Ridley Scott you can't laugh like okay
yeah we'll take it there and then when
they come we'll go down and let's then
we'll go to places that actually could
so I go into really Scott and I pitched
with sue Williams who is a development
executive smart nicest woman and you
know this is really important when
you're pitching is you're trying to get
as much information so I was pitching
her this project and at some point I saw
her body language shift and I go it was
it's something off about that and she
goes really doesn't like these kind of
things I don't think I think this is
really exciting for him but not if it's
going down that road
and like what kind of things is really
like and so she started sharing things
was so helpful so we could kind of
retool the pitch together and so she was
instrumental so when you go someone
you're pitching you know you're trying
to get as much information from that
person and it's a real sometimes writers
have ego and they're like yeah I'm going
in this place and I'm pitching the
little lowest person on the totem pole
oh that's great because you get
information about the decision-maker
okay so sue Williams help me reformulate
the pitch in a way that would be a
better fit for Ridley so that was
amazing and that was I will forever be
grateful for her then I got brought in
to pitch to Mimi who was at the time
Ruth Lee's producing partner and this is
a long pitch this is a almost an hour
pitch it's like a 50-minute pitch this
is not a short pitch I always hate when
people say your pictures have to be this
amount of time there's no rules like
first of all when someone says you have
you have to do your pitch in 10 minutes
people think that people will listen to
you for 10 minutes they'll listen to you
as long as they're interested and if
they're not interested 30 seconds they
tune you out and most pitches that sell
are longer pitches because people want
to have the confidence that this has
been worked out and what they're buying
is legit anyway it says a long pitch so
I'm pitching the Mimi and it can't be
going worse she's sitting back like this
she's not making an eye contact she
looks in pain she looks like this pitch
is so bad that it is making her go crazy
and the only reason I have a career is
at the time I wanted to be doing
stand-up or improv so I was pursuing
that and an improv I was learning that
one of my problems my weaknesses is when
I thought things were going well I was
alive and animated but when I thought
things weren't going about anybody ins
was into it my fear of rejection runs
through this I would sort of back off
and sort of tune out of the scene I kind
of let you guys take it I would just
sort of drop out of the scene which is
you don't do that as an improviser so
what I was being taught is when you
think things are going terrible walk to
the center of the stage take focus and
say something and just stay in there
stay alive don't worry about people's
judgments follow your process so I'm
pitching an after
seven minutes I'm like she hates me she
hates this pitch she's never gonna buy
it she's in pain and that voice says
just do the short version and get out of
here this is painful for her it's
painful for you
Ridley was never gonna buy this pitch
just get out of here just wrap it up and
go which I would do is a stand-up
terrible habit but another voice that
okay look you're never gonna be a writer
as evidenced by the pain you're causing
this woman maybe you could be a
performer so use this as a way of
practicing your improv skills stay
engaged stay engaged that that voice
went through my head so I stay engaged
and I I just did the pitch with gusto
and focus and try not to look too much
at me and see how much pain she was in
and I finished and then there was just
silence
I mean silence and then she stands up
and she goes hmm
I don't get it and then sue Williams
said well what don't you get
she goes all of it and she looked at me
and she was like something like maybe
we'll be in touch or just something and
walked out and Sue didn't know what to
say I didn't have to say and then I left
and I drove home and I called my agent
and I'm like well you were right
Ridley's not gonna buy this then sue
calls me and I pick up the phone you
know and she's like hey when you pitch
with me you were really good but when
you pitched for me me and I know where
this was going she said you were on fire
Mimi I loved it now there's a lesson in
this which is don't try to read the room
because I've pitched two people I
pitched the heads of Studios that
laughed and loved it because they when
someone's hearing a pitch they're trying
to decide am I gonna buy this am I gonna
take this to my boss that's could be
stressful and I pitched to a studio once
where he knew right away he wasn't gonna
buy it because they had a similar idea
in development so he just relaxed and
had fun with me we had a great time but
he already knew he wasn't gonna buy it
I found out Mimi Lake only takes one or
two pitches to Ridley a year and when
she was hearing this pitch she was like
internally going oh my god this is
something really would really love and I
can't speak for her but I'm guessing
that maybe she was nervous because maybe
she was thinking do I really want to put
my career on the line with this guy like
I was a nobody I was in
film school I had I was a was like 23
and green as they came and I think that
she probably hearing the pitch was
having an internal debate you know again
I can't speak forever that's my guess so
Seuss she was like yeah I probably
should have told you she could be a
little like that sort of her way she
listens so don't read people's like I've
been in rooms where people seem like
they hated it and sometimes they do
sometimes they don't stay committed have
integrity do the pitch okay so to your
question sorry for the long wind-up so I
was told that really wouldn't be back in
town for a month Mimi did have one big
concern that she wanted changed it was a
hard creative thing to figure out but
I'm like I have a month to figure it out
few days later I told you I got a phone
call here's what I didn't tell you I
don't drink much alcohol I'm just a
lightweight I'm the cheapest date ever
and the night before I was at some party
and I drank more than I've ever drink in
my life and it doesn't take much to get
me drunk I think that morning might have
been my first ever hangover or was the
worst ever hangover so when the phone
rang I hadn't showered it was I hadn't
shaven I was hungover it was my agent
and she said Ridley's in town and you'd
like to hear the pitch he has an hour
here's a slot in an hour can you hear
the pitch and it takes 45 minutes to get
there to Beverly Hills for more I was
and so I said and it's not a good idea
but I said oh that's exciting
can we bump it up till 2:00 and there
was this long pause and I know my agent
was thinking why did I sign this guy and
she said so Cory Ridley's in town he has
a slot he'd like to hear your pitch in
an hour and at least then I was like of
course I will be there in an hour this
kind of works out to my favor so I
quickly shave and shower and on the dry
drink coffee on the drive over I'm just
figuring out how to solve that creative
problem what happened is I got there
with a second to spare and they dripped
me into the room with him I never had
the chance to get nervous
I never had a chance to psych myself out
I was just on pure adrenaline and Ridley
was the sweetest person ever he came in
the room you know and I started to like
you know it's an honor and it was like
Blade Runner and alien like I it was a
literal honor to be in a room with him
let alone the fact that he was gonna
listen to me he pitched a project and he
just immediately said like I you know
were just too creative people I want to
hear your idea you don't have to be
great at performing my staff loves it I
just want to hear like he went out of
his way to make me feel comfortable and
that I belong there because I did not
feel like I belong to in a room pitching
to really Scott and I was just on
adrenaline with no prep ourselves out
and so I just started talking and he was
just he listened any and he nodded and
he was so receptive and he was so loving
and gentle I'll I'll never forget that
and he was just amazing and then at the
end he asked the question you always
want to hear which is he said so who
else has heard this pitch and I said
nobody you're the first pitch your first
play well who else is going to hear this
pitch and I gave some of the places that
we had meetings set up and he looked at
his staff and then he turned to me and
he said who's your agent and I told him
Dan Karen's I see him and he called my
agent and he said I want to take this
off the market so that was just like I I
really thought I was dreaming and then I
remember I was driving home in my like
cruddy little car and I little in the
Doug's car called it because you had to
use your feet to stop it
thumbskull no money car and I was
driving on the 405 and I started shaking
I just was shaking I had a pullover and
the thought that went through my head
wasn't that I just launched my career it
wasn't that I just sold the thought that
went through my head was I just met
Ridley Scott who's so nerdy
and not only that once the deal was
consummated they said we want you on the
next plane to London so that Ridley and
his team will develop the structure with
you and they meant the literal next
plane to London so my wife and I my
girlfriend at the time now wife Rebecca
we were like she's like I'll help you
pack because I don't know how to pack
and I'm like great and she's getting all
my clothes where's your suitcase I'm
like what I don't have oh so we ran to
like Target and bought a suitcase and
everything and then they flew me
first-class and I didn't know
first-class exists I didn't know what
first-class was I did grew up with no
money so they kept bringing me like food
and wine and I was like no no no like I
was thinking I can't afford this you
know like I can't afford I don't want to
pay for all this when I land and then in
some point in London someone said no in
first-class it's all included so no way
back I was like more food
but yes Ridley just I mean he treated me
throughout the entire process and he
called me when they weren't gonna make
it and he explained why which he didn't
have to do feel what the entire process
he treated me like a like a writer who
belonged to be there and someone that he
wanted he wanted to hear my opinions he
didn't want me just to defer to him I
mean it was amazing
forever be grateful for that he spoiled
me because at some point I was like well
I thought everyone now that's how the
way I'd worked for some of the best
people in the business that's how they
treat writers and I've worked with
people who don't treat writers that way
so when you pulled over on the 405 do
you remember was there a song playing on
the radio or I don't I just write think
I remember I was gonna crash that's a
good question I don't remember I just
kept thinking I thought I came home and
my girlfriend was like so and I'm like I
meant really Scott and she's like I know
you meant Ridley Scott though oh yeah he
bought he bought it I was just I was
just a little film school nerd who was
excited to me Ridley Scott
the best piece of advice I got during
that time was from my girlfriend at the
time and she said you should just write
a movie and then sell it to a studio and
then you can find out how it all really
works and that's why I wrote my first
script and that was a really great piece
of advice and I guess because of me
thinking of it that simply I was able to
sell my first grass like maybe that's
why I don't know I mean it's not it's
obviously not that easy
but in my head it was and so I wrote
this thing and got it out and done that
was probably the best piece worst piece
well no no I mean there were there were
there there were bad begging said to me
weren't necessarily advice like nobody
ever said you know he can go home kid
you bother me but I don't know if I got
a piece of bad advice but I did get that
I did get that advice and I decided to
write and we said we sold that script to
Columbia from the time that she told you
that how did how much time went by when
you started writing that script next day
next day wow this is before Starbucks or
no was around there probably was
Starbucks but I don't drink coffee
oh you know okay I can't I'm one of
those weirdos it doesn't sir
so so you where did you start writing
the script because there I had a friend
who was an aspiring writer
he had final draft so I went to him and
I said hey man I want to write a script
and he was like you want to what I said
just give me the final draft show me how
it worked
he's like doesn't know how final Drive
works with dude whatever just you know I
just just show me how it works so he
taught me how it work he's like you just
do that and hit the tab key and then
write the things like all right it's way
you're gonna write uh-oh
that's one ranked script I'm writing
script well you didn't have an idea no
it's like floating around no no it's
like I'm just gonna write one read them
all my life can't be that hard hard but
I figured just write a script just start
like what am i doing I'm sitting here
and staring at a phone that doesn't ring
you know phone's not going anywhere I'm
not going anywhere I could be sitting
here a year from now and me and my phone
can be hanging out together or I can be
sitting here here from now me and my
phone gonna be hanging out with a script
that I wrote so I started writing and
then I was like I just want to figure
out something that work and at the time
it was like you had all these like it
was like the team stuff was hot so this
is like post screen this is like Cruel
Intentions
and you know i know what you did last
summer when the lights went off in
Georgia or whatever so I was like all
right so they're making this stuff and
everything was in high school so I was
like okay I'll put something in college
all right what's the story they all seem
to be horrors and thrillers okay
yeah so I started looking at films that
were really really popular like in the
80s take that story that basic idea said
it in college now then I got a thing
that's a proven track-record that works
but then I got this other thing and it's
new when it's fresh and it's different
and that became the first script that
became I would die for you it was about
a guy going to Santa Barbara
UC Santa Barbara and had a girlfriend
and life was good and but he his in his
hometown was getting married so he goes
back to his home town for the wedding
without his girlfriend because she was
off to learn whatever and he runs into
his ex-girlfriend from high school and
she and he end up you know and he leaves
he says you know it's a mistake whatever
was good to see you goes back to his
life and you see Santa Barbara turns
around
there's the ex-girlfriend hey how are
you what's up this your girlfriend oh my
god she's so great
now the girlfriend loves the
ex-girlfriend and he's in hell and that
became that became I would die for you
and Coloma you bought that out well he
had a good time with it was fun how long
did it take you to write it no it's good
it's good it's good uh three weeks three
weeks
Wow
how many drafts did you do
before I sold it three maybe four
well it wasn't it wasn't a lot and into
a lot of drafts how did you get access
to pitch Columbia oh oh oh yeah okay
sorry
oh no then yes I was still sort of
making a living as an actor you know and
you know yeah they were by that time I
had done murder one and NYPD Blue so
they were like really healthy residuals
floating around
I had residual from murder one one-year
night of years like one day I just went
as a residual was like $15,000 from her
tomorrow I bought a car it was great so
that was where that was at that time and
I had a friend who was a comedian and he
had a buddy who was a manager a literary
manager and I called my comedian friend
up his name's a mad
I met him ed and he says hey man I said
I got the script man I'm I think it's
really good I want to sell it
he's like you should call Brian dude
Brian's a manager now you should call
him up give me your script see what you
can do I was like okay so I sent it to
Brian and Brian was like so what do you
want to do is like dude I don't care
like I don't care if they want to turn
into pigs on the moon it'll be pigs on
the moon I don't care I just want to
sell things I won't find out how it
works cuz nobody will tell me how it
works this whole thing so I could find
out how everything works he's like all
right cool
so he sat he read it gave me some notes
went back and forth through the notes
and so then once he was happy with it he
decided to do like a soft what do they
call it not pitch when the agents and
managers they send it out I don't know
soft send out I don't know that they
have a name for it I can't remember but
he sent it out to a few people as
opposed to like a blanket thing you know
cuz usually you know you go wide with it
you send it out to all the studios and
all the production companies and you see
who bites so he's like I'm gonna send
that to people I know first see what
they think
see how it plays and then we'll go
bigger I was like all right cool so at
the time there was a production company
cannot remember the name and production
company they had a deal at Warner
Brothers and the executive at the
production company was chanting Dungey
and Channing is actually now I believe
she's the head of drama at ABC now but
she read it and she was like oh good I
like this I wanna go out with it and she
did the same thing Bryan did she was
like I'm gonna go why I'm just gonna guy
guy friend I'm gonna see how a place so
she sent it to a woman named Carrie
Richman and Carrie was an executive at
Columbia at Sony so she took it to carry
and carry ready and Carrie was like I
like it
it was good has anybody else seen it
she's like no no I seen it I yet tell
you what we're gonna make a pre-emptive
thing we don't make an option yeah let's
do it and we did it and that's how the
first one happened see I didn't want to
be vague about it that's how it actually
happened that's how it actually happened
so it wasn't like you know there wasn't
like a big sort of well they call it dos
machina it wasn't like a big thing that
just sort of like landed
you know CAA didn't just show up and go
oh that didn't happen it was the manager
and he knew some folks though they knew
some folks and then everybody loved the
script it all came back to me like this
script and as I've continued I've
realized now it comes down to that it
all comes down to the words on these
pieces of paper we dig those so let's
see what we can do that's what it's
always come down to in my experience I
had just come off of my first television
series it was the very first television
series ever on cable it was called
brothers it was on Showtime it ran for
five years
and I had come off of that show and now
I had one year and so this day that
you're asking about occurred I had gone
through one calendar year of going of
having deals made for 12 new shows okay
so I went out on my auditions it was me
and a couple of other people you know
signed my contracts everything was ready
and I didn't get one of the shows not
one of them so this isn't auditions that
I didn't get these are deals that were
made for me that if I had walked out of
the room with the job I would have had
another television series and I went one
calendar year twelve of those events and
didn't get one it was down to me and two
other women and most discouraged okay
one of the episodes was down to one of
the pilots was down to me and nobody
else and I still didn't get it because
the producer writer decided that she
wanted to play the role now none of
those shows ever went on to become
serious but that didn't mitigate my
feelings on this particular day and I
was crushed I mean it it was the hardest
I couldn't believe that this is what had
happened again in this year and I
literally went on my face on the rug and
I just wept and wept and wept and I and
then I said God you know if this I just
want peace I want to be happy if you
think that I'm supposed to move to
Kansas raised chickens that have babies
I'll do it
I just want a sign I have to know I have
to know something I can't take this any
longer this this amount of continual
rejection after getting so close to so
many things and uh and I stopped crying
because I really liked the rug and I was
getting schmutz on it so I had to quit
but so after right after I said the
thing I need a sign I have to have
something that is unequivocal the phone
rang it was my agent I was
an audition for a movie with the then
very old and ailing I believe Robert
Mitchum but it was still Robert Mitchum
and it was an old movie star and I'd
watched him when I was a little girl and
and I was really excited about the
audition and and oh and then I had been
something about I had this feeling I
often will open a book you know with a
metaphysical or spiritual or just and
just see what I see right and I opened
up I think it was the Bible and it was
something about returning home as ecco
desert Zephyr returning you home and I
got this so I need a sign the phone
rings I have this audition than I do the
thing I get the reading about the Zephyr
that feeling to go home I got this
overwhelming desire to return to Aspen
Colorado which is where my parents owned
their own legitimate theater when I was
a child and I so I said I'm gonna do it
and I made reservations and the name of
the plane
the train that went there was the Zephyr
and and I went on the audition I didn't
get it but I had my sign interest you
know it was if this is all I said if
this is just my vanity let me know
because I don't want to do this any
longer
and if it's not if I it's not I felt
like this is what I was supposed to do
all the signs when I came here I got
work right away I got my sag card right
away I got an agent right away and and
and then I didn't work for a while you
know and then I got jobs here and got
jobs there and and you know waited tape
would did waited cocktails at the improv
and at the Comedy Store and all that in
between gigs and and and so so I got in
all these signs so I really believed
that this and I grew up onstage and this
is what I love and so I thought well you
know I've had all these other signs that
things are right that's what I thought I
was supposed to be doing but you let me
know if I'm not and so when that call
came I felt well that is definitely a
sign you know so and then
I think oh and then I went away on the
trip and I came back home and on my deck
outside my door was a script for Murder
She Wrote and an offer to come and do it
no audition Wow just on the basis of the
work of mine that they'd seen before
they offered me the job and I thought
well that's my debt that's my
exclamation point on the signed that I
asked for but that day Karen that day I
rung me out I ran into a very inspiring
man whose name was Norman Cousins who
was the editor of Saturday Review world
in those days and he came to speak in a
class of mine at Occidental College and
it turned out we shared a motto that no
one else in the world had ever heard of
and that motto was a was a single
sentence by the philosopher Nash
philosopher or take a guess a that said
I think the only immoral thing is for a
being not to use every instant of its
existence with the utmost intensity and
I had never heard anyone else quote that
but after after his taught in my class I
asked him to come to my office and
showed him that it was framed above my
desk and so needless to say we bonded
and long story short I asked him you
know what I should do when I grow up
which I asked male authority figures all
my life basically and he he told me
after we got to know each other that I
should consider the entertainment
business because it was much broader
than the academic world and people can
basically do whatever you know it
anything creative you're encouraged to
do basically you could find your own way
there are no rules and schedules and all
of those kinds of things that we find in
academia and I love academic you know
the world and the ideas that are
exchanged and all of that but it was
restricting and it was you know for me
suffocating which is a word that
as means a lot to me personally it's my
most ancient nightmare is being
suffocated and I've never been
suffocated and you know in the
entertainment world I've been terrified
a lot but not suffocated and so he
encouraged me and I thought well I don't
know anything about the entertainment
world other than movies that it seemed
that's it and he showed me a passage
from a book by William Goldman that I
hope everyone knows called adventures in
the screen trade and the passage was
that the only important rule in
Hollywood is that nobody knows anything
and I thought well that's that's good
means it's a level playing field so I
set out to learn as much as I could and
I realized that I wasn't 18 years old in
the mailroom at William Morris and I
wasn't you know infinitely wealthy and I
didn't have relatives in the film
business those are like the three main
ways to get into the business normally
so I thought I just have to be smarter
so I started writing reading contracts I
remember a producer he'll never forget I
asked if I could read a distribution
contract and he said yeah I can let you
read it but I can't let you take it out
of my office you can go up in the other
room and have a cappuccino and but you
know do that so I read it and I came
back an hour later and I said I'm
confused about some things I read here
can I ask you a couple questions and he
said sure and he I said this paragraph
number 48 in the fine print section at
the end says that accounting terms used
in this Agreement shall be redefined by
the 20th century-fox
accounting department at such time if
any that litigation is entered into
among the parties I said what does that
mean and he said that is not in there I
go yes it is let me show you how I
showed it true and he said I can't
believe that that's still in there mate
my attorney should have crossed that out
he had just signed the agreement and I
said well they didn't so I started
learning that's how I started learning
reading contracts was I think whatever
kind of thing you're trying to do if
it's successful ends up with being a
bunch of contracts so you might as well
start backwards with the contracts and
long story short while I was preparing
myself that way over a six-month period
I I came up with an idea that I sold
basically on a wing and a prayer not
knowing how to do it but it ended up
being within the next 12 months 16
movies that I was completely in charge
of and raised half the money from Warner
Brothers and half the money from from a
company in Canada went up to Montreal
and shot them all back to back meaning
one movie ended on Friday and the next
one began on Monday and it was a series
of romantic comedies and it came out of
my teaching romantic literature and also
teaching publishing because a publisher
was talking in one up in my publishing
class the visiting publisher was talking
to my class and he was telling me he was
telling us what goes on the cover of a
romance novel and I realized as he
listed the things that were on the cover
that he was basically reciting the rules
of courtly love that I was teaching in
another class that were written in the
12th century by andreas capital honesty
the Chaplin of Marie de France and and I
thought so
maybe romance novels that everyone makes
fun of are just an extension of these
ancient courtly stories these love
stories and I came up with the idea of
doing a series of movies that imitated
these love stories and were marketing
friendly because they all had colors so
you could have put all the DVDs on the
you know on the shelf and they would
form a rainbow so they were all called
things like The Rose cafe sunset court
indigo autumn etc and we did sixteen of
them and by that time I was
was fully in the business because I was
in charge of production as a creative
production and within three movies my
assistant I were you know we knew we
were doing whereas we did not have any
idea what we were doing before the first
movie started shooting and then I came
back to Los Angeles and became a
literary manager because I didn't have
resources to option properties but as a
literary manager you can produce
properties by managing the property and
that's what got me going and ever since
then so it was that was how the
transition occurred and it was just
because I thought of an idea and I
didn't know better if I known now what
you know what if I'd known then what I
know now I would never have sold it the
way I sold it I simply went out with the
concept and convinced several Studios to
look at it seriously and none of them
had looked at a script or anything like
that and one of them Warner Brothers
wanted to see a script and I wouldn't
show it to them
until they'd signed an agreement and
they ended up signing an agreement in
three days and then I showed them they
manufactured the scripts over the
weekend by putting out a call to the
romance novel community and getting back
you know ideas for the script and so on
so it was a fluke and one of the hardest
things about being in the business when
you're been in it for a while is the
there grows up this huge accumulation of
experience that you have that makes you
know that you shouldn't just pick up the
phone and call the head of a studio and
and I have to overcome that I just
reached out to the head of a studio this
morning but every time I do it it's like
having a 500-pound weight in your hand
to pick up the phone because you know
that's wrong but somebody like me back
then I didn't know what was wrong so I
you know it was light as the light
motion to pick up the phone and call
call somebody and so whenever I get a
new partner who's not involved I always
say don't be afraid to tell me your
craziest ideas
because this is a world in which crazy
ideas work and you know it's it's the
traditional ideas that have our harder
time working so it is a completely wild
and entrepreneurial frontier it's
probably the last frontier of American
culture though the movie business and
it's been changing ever since I've been
in it it constantly changes from a world
in which video cassettes dominated and
you could find them everywhere and to a
world in which we're down streaming from
Netflix and Hulu and so on and the
delivery methods have always changed and
what doesn't change and this is the
encouraging thing for writers is that
the need for stories has only gotten
greater and greater with the
proliferation of hundreds of channels
they all have one thing in common they
need programming they need content and
writers are the ones who create the
content the intellectual property so
they should be hugely encouraged you
don't have to understand all the
distribution methods you just need to
know how to tell a story and and you're
in good shape
just keep telling stories I pursued
being a film major in my undergraduate
in Ohio which is my home state and got a
four-year degree BFA and motion picture
production which of course guarantees
you a job in the industry immediately
when you show up with that and then I
just thought I was gonna move to Los
Angeles and become an assistant because
I kind of knew you know that whole
starting the William Morris mailroom
kind of thing that I knew that that was
a thing you could do there were people
that had moved out to LA from Dayton
Ohio where I was from before me who'd
gone to my film school before me who had
these kind of jobs working as assistants
at the studios and stuff so I decided
that's gonna be my path I'm gonna get it
my day job will be one of those kind of
jobs where I'll be like a secretary and
I'll just be writing on the side and so
that's what I pursued and was lucky
enough to get into the Fox Studios kind
of in-house temp pool where somebody in
the human resources department had all
these temps that every day they would
assign to these different jobs
throughout the studio where they needed
somebody to fill
in for a day or a week or a month or
whatever because some assistant was on
maternity leave or out sick or had just
left and they hadn't replaced them yet
so I got my taste of all these different
kinds of jobs throughout 20th Century
Fox and the Fox Network you know
everything from like legal department to
accounting and Finance like very
corporate departments but also some of
the eventually the more creative side
where you're working on a TV show or
working for a production company which
is of course what you really want if
you're an aspiring writer and so I did
that for a number of years and
eventually got assigned to Tom Hanks his
production company just as a temp which
turned into a full-time assistant job
working there where it was basically him
and his his main assistant who went with
him on location and had been with him
for years and me I was like the guy in
the office like answering the phone and
opening the mail he was off shooting
Forrest Gump for like five months at one
point you know on the East Coast and I
was the only one there in the office
kind of holding down the fort so to
speak at his little production company
that was based at Fox at that time so
while I was doing that I was writing
scripts on the side and I had worked as
a writer's assistant on the show picket
fences right before I worked for Tom
Hanks and got to know other people at my
level other assistants which is a really
helpful thing to do you know they say do
you have to move to Los Angeles to be a
screenwriter you don't have to it helps
and but one of the main reasons it can
help is if you're the kind of person
that gets a job in the business like
that where you're around people doing
what you want to be doing and you meet
people at your level who are also trying
to do the kinds of things you want to do
and you can sort of help each other and
that certainly worked out for me because
I switched from writing features on spec
to I took a class at UCLA extensions
writers program where I have taught now
in recent years myself on sitcom writing
I started writing a spec script for the
show Fraser in that class and then when
it was done I showed it to this friend
I'd worked with on picket fences who was
a fellow assistant but also an aspiring
writer who had just gotten an agent and
she liked the Fraser and was willing to
show it to her agent and the agent like
the Fraser enough to want to sign me so
I got this agent while I was still
working as an assistant for Tom Hank
and this agent function kind of like
managers do now managers weren't such a
thing back then where she was giving me
notes
you know she signed me off it but then
she immediately wanted me to rewrite it
with all these notes she gave me before
she would send it to anyone and so then
she had me after that was done she had
me start my next one which was a mad
about you and after that of friends so I
was like pumping out these sitcom spec
scripts because in those days when you
wanted to work on staff on a show in the
90s they more valued specs of existing
shows whereas nowadays it's its original
pilots that writers tend to use for the
writing samples to get into TV writing
you know a staff job like that which is
normally how you get in is you know you
get hired as like a staff writer on a
show if you're one of the lucky few
fortunate few so that's the direction I
was headed but I still had the the Tom
Hanks really great sort of assistant day
job but I was really starting to think
eventually I'm gonna be a professional
writer now I mean I have an agent she's
sending my stuff out I got some meetings
here and there but then things took a
funny turn an amazing turn which is that
one day Tom Hanks read one or two of
those scripts because his assistant who
I worked kind of under I think
recommended oh you should have Tom read
your you know it'd be fun whatever I
don't know I was never gonna ask him to
read my stuff or help me in any way cuz
I knew this is my job this is he's not
there to help me do that and he
apparently liked the one or two scripts
he read and decided that I had Talent
and he told me my talents are being
wasted and he offered me this like
amazing life-changing promotion the week
of my 30th birthday I had a wife and a
kid and she was a teacher and I was
making seven hundred hours a week I
think or something like that so it was a
really a good time to get a promotion
where I was gonna help him basically
help him develop this miniseries he had
sold to HBO as an executive producer
which was from the earth to the moon
which was about the Apollo space program
he had done the movie Apollo 13 and was
a life long space junkie and at this
point was the biggest star in Hollywood
he had gotten to that point
by then and so he was able to sell this
idea for a miniseries of very expensive
12 hour miniseries where we would
dramatize and recreate the
I are Apollo program right all these
other missions you know so I then helped
him kind of figure out the sort of
outline for that and like find writers
to write the episodes you know
professional screenwriters that were
already established unlike me but
eventually I got to write one of the
scripts and then eventually that script
became a decent script because it took a
long time and then I got asked to help
rewrite some of the other scripts so by
the end of that production from the
earths of the moon I had kind of been an
apprentice producer on the whole thing
so I got a co-producer credit on the
whole thing and I had writing credit or
pieces of writing credit on several
episodes and I just like learned all
this stuff from just being on it from
beginning to end and being able to be
kind of in the middle of it because I
worked for Tom and he was the executive
producer so I was on the set in the
editing room and did everything or
watched everything and so when it won
the Emmy for Best miniseries and all the
other big awards I got to share in those
awards because I was one of the
producers so that was really how I got
my start I was very fortunate and that
the first thing I wrote professionally
not only got produced which you know
most things the writers get paid to
write still don't get produced right you
can make a whole career writing things
that don't get produced not only did it
get produced but I was a producer on it
and one these major awards for being
that so it was kind of a fairy tale
beginning of a career that hat that I
owe to Tom Hanks and to you know this is
a combining which you wouldn't think
translates into historical drama about
the space program but I somehow managed
to figure out how to how to write for
that series even though it wasn't the
kind of stuff I was doing on my own and
then an interesting sort of audition
story that I tell a lot again this is
something I learned when The Fast and
the Furious audition came my way again
where I was at in my time at that time
in my life I didn't realize what I had I
was off in my own sort of thinking about
what I thought about the business I got
the audition and it was called red line
action
at the time and I I remember passing on
the audition and why because I just
didn't wanna I had in my mind I wanted
to do something completely different
with my life at the time again maybe 23
years old you know so I got the audition
I passed got the audition twice I passed
right my agent at the time calls me up
and says what are you doing like you
really want to pass on this and I said
yeah I mean I was just being a little
punk just like fine hung up the phone on
me I'm like yeah right my mom making
decision decisions another agent from
the same agency called me up and he said
you know come on go in and I'm like okay
I'll go in I was being a brat I was
being a brat and I Wayne Isham and I met
the director Rob Cohen he's very
friendly and so nice and the caching
director who I love and so I auditioned
and and they liked what I did and then
they called me back or they want me to
come back and read with a couple of the
other actors and so I'm like and then
you start sad life sort of play in your
mind like oh oh you like me okay you
know all right yeah yeah I'll go back
yeah sure so I go in and I'd read with
whether he was Matt Schulze at the time
and I'm Johnny strong I believe and they
were trying to fit like the guys that
you know cuz they already had you know
Paul and VIN and everybody and I ain't
it up booking this movie I got the part
and and I'm like wow this is really cool
and we're gonna do all these cars and
then we got on set and it became you
know this crazy thing and everyone's
gonna be like oh it's gonna be it's
gonna be huge it's gonna be this big
moving I'm like no I just don't I don't
I don't think so I was just so locked
into this into this brain of mine and
then lo and behold it became like a huge
phenomenon and it changed my life
instantly and it taught me I can
that you never never never no don't
don't turn down an audition don't don't
be silly you know and I was really silly
and I tell this story and not that I was
so appreciative that I went in and I was
given that opportunity and it changed my
life forever forever so I learned a
valuable lesson then you know just you
know keep your mind open you know
appreciate what you have if it comes
when you're 19 if it comes when you're
40 just appreciate that moment so how
long before then you get your next job
which is the wedding scene so meanwhile
Adam was having his career was going in
a really good way and I was determined
not to come to LA without a movie
because I knew everybody was a director
and and Adam had seen the movie and
loved it and I remember he had his agent
see it and they're like I was cool you
know and the fact that they did a movie
Gavin couldn't wait for me to direct his
movies he had done I think Billy Madison
by then he called me up and said I'm
working on a comedy album he already
made you movie come to LA come for two
weeks and help me with the comedy album
and it was an album called what the hell
happened to me so I wrote it on a bunch
of skits I acted on some of them and
then I did a music video for one of the
songs it was T polychron appleís it's
kind of a precursor to the wedding
singer because it was an 80s bully but
it was all about 80's wardrobe Stone
wash pants and and the bi-level haircut
and I shot this video and I didn't
realize like all eyes because Adam was
just starting to really excel every
bigwig in town came to see who's this
Frank Karachi guide direct in the video
and I'm just loving it because I'm
getting like real equipment and you know
and and it had like all the comedians
that were friends with David Spade
Rob Schneider so many interesting cameos
it was like David Arquette Garry
Shandling was in it so it's this really
fun crazy silly video and then I on the
album
we did a twenty-three city tour the
album went double platinum it was like
one of the biggest Sandler album so it
was a good little run where I literally
came for two weeks and a bag of clothes
for two weeks and I didn't stop working
I got an editing system in our house you
know we had the house and Beverly Hills
and I was like editing all the videos
myself I'm like this is great like film
school again I'm like this got me 20:28
something like that and I'm like I can't
believe I'm getting to like live with my
friends shoot stuff people really seeing
it edit I'm like this is a dream come
true and then we did the 23 city tour
like it was a rock and roll tour with a
bunch of Adams comedy songs so like the
Hanukkah song he did a bunch of other
songs like the Halloween song
piece-of-shit car a lot of ones you know
though like the turkey song for
Thanksgiving and I did sort of very
inexpensive I came up with the stage
design it was an outdoor drive-in movie
in the summer and it was like beach
balls and all this stuff and and and I
had the set designer from his movies do
the sadness and I had a screen and on
the screen I would do things like there
was a song about grandmothers so I got a
bunch of grandmothers shot him on green
screen dancing with spatulas and then I
took like contact paper from like you
know like Grandma contact paper that
you'd put in the kitchen oh yeah like
really corny powdery and I green-screen
them again I just think it was like this
weird it would be inspired by like a
Pink Floyd drug video but it was just
silly comedy for stoners and then the
other thing is we had a skit that like
it was a superstone or skids ever loved
there was a talking goat and the talking
goat these for stoners come across his
talking goat in van nuys tied to the
back of the truck and they're like oh
she the talking go Adam two divorces ago
like hey guys that was your time yeah
I'm kind of more deer and I played the
old man who used to beat the goat and
and and so that skit was just the most
popular one and that's like all I got if
someone goat for the concert because the
kids love it and I say kids they're like
20 year olds and were 30 at the time and
so the goat opens up this show and
people go nuts and then I bring them
back a few times and new line had seen
the show and they were like we want to
do a talking goat movie and and and
we're like oh that's cool but like we
were thinking of doing another movie
though and then we pitched them I wanted
to do a movie that was an 80s movie and
Adam and Tim had to come up an idea for
a wedding singer who gets jilted and has
to perform weddings after he has his
heart broken and then I said Adam let's
make that 80s because then you can sing
songs and won't look like you're trying
to be cool it'll be a little retro it'll
take the curse off and he's a great and
then we pitched that and it's funny
because there was 1995-96 we're pitching
an 80s movie and people like 80s that
was six years ago and I know trust me
like we just different like I have the
same clothes from six years ago like
trust me no no and then like sure enough
I made I learned my first miss my first
thing not to do in Hollywood when I was
pitching the producer I go think of how
in Dazed & Confused the 70s was a
personality and then the producer was
like Dazed and Confused made like ten
million dollars why would you reference
that movie and I'm like no no just how
cool it was and I'm like oh I get it you
just got to when you want to get money
you have the reference it didn't
translate I was like no it's how cool
all right it's like the Titanic
no that was that okay so anyway so we
pitched that and they loved the idea and
then we had we kind of worked on a
script and then Carrie Fisher
new line hired her to spend time on the
script because she was such the the
script doctor for romantic movies and I
got to spend just got to LA you know
what my gym bag I'd only been there for
a few months and next thing you know I'm
at Carrie Fisher's house I'd have to go
to her house every day when she was
writing she would literally lay in bed
and write it she would watch TV she'd go
let's watch old movies and then I'd
literally be laying in bed when Carrie
Fisher you and I can't believe I'm in
bed with Princess Leia not you right
just working not nothing and and yeah we
watched these old movies and she showed
me
all these great oh you know we're all
romantic comedies Roman holiday
like he named him breasts Breakfast at
Tiffany's and then we would write and
and it was great and we got to make this
amazing story and then drew signed on
and and before you know it I'm like
awesome - Mike Wow
I came I still have not gone home ice
loved this bag of clothes and I'm
directing the wedding singer and uh and
I remember the first day pulling up on
Sunset the house we shot was with the
old lady with the meatballs Rosie and
its first time driving the set right I'm
driving my will rental Honda Civic and
I'm like why are these trucks here I'm
like I'm used to making a student phone
we had one truck there was like truck
after truck and it's a low-budget movie
is like a ten million dollar movie I was
so intimidated by the time I walked to
said that there was all this equipment
I'm like I need some valley track in the
camera I didn't know you need all this
and then yeah but I jumped right in and
and I just did what I knew how to do and
I rose oh now I have a lot of crew when
you change things that just happens fast
and yeah and when we made that movie we
had no idea it was gonna hit like it was
a little low budget movie and I just
blew up in a whole different way and
then I thought now I'm fucked because
now I can't make all those little weird
movies okay why because you thought now
you're gonna be pigeonholed yeah yeah
and I was like and then actually the
finding was we I was like come on we're
on a roll let's do the waterboy so the
wedding singer didn't even open we made
the waterboy and so in the middle of
doing the waterboy the wedding singer
opened we flew home for the premiere and
it was like wow it was great knowing now
there's no pressure on the waterboy like
they gave us more money in time we
didn't feel like you know when you're
making a movie of a gun to your head
with budget and yeah but I did find it
for a long time I was pigeon-holed I had
so many little movies I wanted to do and
I'd be willing to do it for no money and
it was once they put you in that box in
Hollywood it's hard to and I didn't know
enough
about how the business works to figure
out how to make the little movie Lily
took me 10 movies till I got to make
another little indie you know and I've
all along I didn't want to you know and
the movie I just made know how they're
ticking like seven years to get that
together the little ones are really hard
to get going just cuz yeah it's always
talent driven you know so you have to
find a piece of talent they want to do
it I went to the University of Texas and
they used to do this thing called The
Hollywood showcase where they would take
an hour's worth of student films and
they would show it out here in LA at the
DGA theater and they would invite a
alumni alumni alumni of the university
just to come and see the short film just
to see like what are the kids doing back
at school and so the year I graduated I
had written I'd written a short film
that played and I had written and
directed another one side too including
a puppet short that ended up becoming
the inspiration for the happy time
earners but so I was you know living in
Austin I was delivering pizza I was
gonna move to Chicago and do second city
in the new to New York because you know
I grew up thinking like LA like
Hollywood like sella what am I going to
sell out and and so they picked two of
my short films to play at this thing and
I graduated like on Saturday a couple
days later like I came to LA just to go
to the screening just cuz I'd never been
LA before and I just graduated I was
like I'll go to the Hollywood Walk of
Fame I'll go to the beach and so I go to
the screening and there was an agent at
the screening who just happened to go to
my college and he was just there to see
the shorts and he liked my short film so
much that he walked up to me at the
reception afterwards and said hey I
loved your short film have you written
any features before cuz I'm a literary
agent I represent writers and I said
well I wrote one for class like I took a
screenwriting class and he's like oh
we'll send it to me I'd love to read it
and I was like sure so I got his card
and I went back to
Austin and I mailed it to him this is
Beck back in the day were you mailed
people things and I just kept delivering
pizza saving up money to move to Chicago
and then a couple months later he called
me and he just said hey we've read your
script and we love it we want to sign
you and represent you as a writer but
you have to move to Los Angeles you
can't move to Chicago because we want to
be able to send you to meetings and I
was like okay so I was like out
delivering pizza and I went back and I
was like I'm out I'm moving Hollywood
and just from this short these short
films that I had done that got someone's
attention and you know and I know if the
story is ridiculous and then I was 22
years old and I was plucked from
obscurity but also part of the story is
you know I had these short films that
somebody saw and when he came to me and
said what else do you have I was able to
say well I have this script that I wrote
you know when I gave it to him and he
read that he liked it
and so you know I have a lot of friends
who make short films or you know who as
a calling card which is an amazing
calling card is a short film to get
people's attention and I always tell
them like you have to be prepared for if
someone's cheat your short film and
likes it and then they say what else do
you have what do you have any features
like do you have something you have to
be able to say yes like here is the
other thing because I have a lot of
friends who have this short that they've
worked really hard on and they'll go
play a festival or something and then
they'll meet an agent or a producer and
then the agent will say what else do you
have and they're like well no I've got
some ideas like of stuff I want to try
to start working on but nothing right
now like you can't do that you have to
have something ready to go that's my
piece of advice so this is actually a
really funny story
so I was I graduated and I was living in
Austin and I was I was moving out of my
apartment because for I was going to
spend six months living with a friend of
mine in her spare bedroom
saving up money over the summer and into
just like I graduated in May when you
and then I was gonna move in January so
I had like seven months where I was just
gonna deliver a pizza and make money and
so I had to move out of my apartment so
I moved everything out of my apartment
except my answering machine the only
thing that was still in my apartment is
this is before I don't even got a cell
phone yet this 2001 so I had an
answering machine and when I gave that
agent a business card by the way still
my agent
so my last day here we are sixteen years
later when I gave him a Mike card in Los
Angeles the only number that was on it
was my apartment in Austin because I
have a cell phone so the only way he had
of contacting me was to call my
apartment so I hadn't heard from him for
like two or three months or whatever I
was like oh I guess he never got my
scare after didn't read my script so the
only thing left in my apartment was my
answering machine so I went and I moved
to everything over the new place and
then I had to go back clean and then
take the answering machine away so I go
back to clean and there's a red light
blinking on the answering machine and I
was like oh I have a message and a beep
there's like hey Todd it's a Steven from
the counter agency rule II read your
script give me a call had I had I gotten
to my apartment like an hour earlier and
unplug the machine I just never would
have gotten a call from him who knows if
he would have tried to track me down by
some other means but um but but that
message was waiting for me and they were
only thing left in my apartment was that
answering machine so knocking on wood
that was really lucky but I then got a
cell phone and I stayed in Austin for
like three months delivering pizza
because I still needed to save up money
to move to LA it's just cousin I had an
agent didn't mean I was like a rich or
something I still needed to afford to
move to LA so delivering pizzas saving
up money I bought a cell phone and I
gave it to my agent my agent my new cell
phone number
and he took my scripts that I wrote for
class and he gave me some notes on it
and I did a new draft and then he sent
it around town as a spec script and he
showed it to a bunch of producers and
like I didn't know what that meant and
so I'm I'm out on a delivery in Austin
and my phone rings and it's my Hollywood
agent and he's like Todd hey we went out
with your script and we just set it up
at Paramount at the it was kelsey
Grammer's company at the time Graham net
and I was like oh oh cool like I don't
know what that means what does that mean
and he's like well it's $10,000 option
plus you're gonna get writers guild
minimum of 27,000 to do the guaranteed
rewrite and I was just like I'm sorry
what what he's like yeah so it's a
guaranteed $37,000 and I was just like I
was like that's more money than I've
ever even heard of imagining because I'm
making like $7 an hour at this piece of
place so I was it was like a dream I was
like I couldn't believe it
and I went back to the double Dave's
pizza where I worked and I walked in and
I was like I'm out I quit I'm Hollywood
now but then I'm a nice guy so I
actually finished my shift oh that's
good I think I even finished work one
more shift but then I but then I quit
and then I moved to LA but that being
said I did there and learn the harsh
realities of like I then it's not like
everything I wrote got sold or I got
jobs that easy like I thought that's how
it works because my first script out the
gate like I got optioned and got it
rewrite so I was just like oh every
script I ever write now it's gonna get
optioned and set up but no it took it
took a while for it to happen again
the second time I hit lightning in a
bottle that first time and I moved out
to LA thinking like I'm a wunderkind I'm
an awesome young hotshot 22 year old and
then the harsh realities of being a
working writer actually set in and I got
I got
how soon after that oh pretty soon
pretty soon pretty soon like I wrote
another script you know I moved out I
wrote another script and I'm like cool
let's show this one I'm sure I'm gonna
set this one up and no one cared feel
really nuff
now what else I was like oh and then
years I mean years went by before I
actually set up another one of my own
scripts because you know I learned very
quickly that when you want to be a
working writer it's not like you write
scripts and then go sell them to people
most jobs you're ever gonna work are you
writing scripts for other people based
on their ideas or pre-existing material
so it's not like people are looking for
original scripts as much it is hey we
need a writer to rewrite that draft of
the Ninja Turtles movie or you know we
bought the IP for some 80s cartoon and
we need a writer to write a script for
it and so I very quickly realized like
oh I actually have to work really hard
now to go to meetings and meet producers
and try to get an assignment that's what
it's called - in order to get paid it's
so like right stuff and for years that's
all I did I mean today it's at this day
that's my primary source of income is I
just do assignment work which is a hard
job like you spend half your time trying
to get the next assignment and then the
little free time you do have you try to
work on an original script that you
hopefully can sell to someone someday
early success wasn't really success I
would say hi I wouldn't really call it
early success I it was I don't even view
it that way I view it as six years of no
one wanting my stuff and it was you know
some random person who was very kind was
interested in a script but it wasn't as
if it was all of a sudden I made it and
I it's happening now so it really was a
six seven year journey to selling my
first project which was recount and why
I didn't give up I think is because I
had something to say and I loved writing
these scripts and they were important to
me and I I loved working on stories and
it just was artists
equally extremely fulfilling where my
acting career was very frustrating and
sometimes I and I worked I didn't really
seem worked on some terrific shows that
I'm really proud of but I wasn't
actually getting to act very much so
even when you're working you know I
would do episodes of Gilmore Girls and I
would do four episodes of season and I
would work on it a day or two and that
would be one of my only jobs for six
months so it's really about seven days
on set over a six month period so what
am i doing the rest of the time I'm
auditioning and trying to get new jobs
but that's a hour a day maybe so really
it was it was a creative outlet for me
of taking my creative energy and putting
it into something where I could actually
just go do it whereas an actor you have
to be picked to go do it and then you
rarely get picked so I just found it
fulfilling but I also was getting
rejected and left and right script after
script and agents managers production
company everyone didn't want my work for
six seven years and I think I got to a
point where I asked myself well this is
not going well
what are you what do you want from this
what what are you doing and I sort of I
asked myself would I and it's one of the
key questions in the movie would I do
this for the rest of my life if I got
nothing in return and I thought yeah I
would and then I just kept writing and
then eventually it wasn't as if six
months later crack the champagne it was
maybe three years later that I sold
recount as a pitch to HBO and then just
kind of went on from there but there was
a certain peace in knowing that it
wasn't about it wasn't about selling
something or success even though I
really wanted it I wasn't and what you
know wasn't a kumbaya moment but there
was a peace in knowing that well
whatever happens you just keep writing
so just keep writing and that's what I
did yeah and I saw that you willed that
I think did two parts of the movie that
that premise yeah which I think is a big
eye-opener to a lot of people that's
something that most people
not be ready for yeah and look at what
JD Salinger did right he stopped
publishing at the height of his fame and
then continued writing for 45 years for
nothing in return and he wrote every day
and he just did it because he just
wanted to write and I think to me that's
what makes this story a profound story
is the journey of the artist and he goes
from being a young man who all he wants
his success to being an older writer
which all he wants is to just create his
art and nothing else and that's that's
the journey that's the the Aesop fable
of this movie where I grew up was as bad
as far from the film industry as as
could be
well not as give me I'm sure I could
have grown up in Siberia too but I grew
up in a small village in South Wales and
really had zero idea of you know how you
might penetrate the film industry or
television and yeah it was sort of just
through lucky I mean again I think me
taking some risks and some Gamble's and
then and then some happy accidents that
I sort of found my way eventually to SNL
there's a so long story in-between
obviously but yeah I essentially I came
I went to New York alright knowing again
I wanted to work in film television no
idea what to do New York seems like the
direction to head LA fell like too much
of a cultural leap at the time and and
yeah I you know I just I had about five
jobs it's sort of my first six months
there I was sort of catering and and
we're working in stores and all that
stuff and then luckily I've got a job in
a post-production facility that edited
commercials and I was working as a
receptionist I did that was there for
about two weeks I think when Jim
Signorelli who is the longtime film
director at SNL so it came in to work on
something and I just saw I mean we ended
up chatting and at at lunch time and
randomly about two weeks after that he
called up and just said that his
assistant was leaving
and did I want to come and work for him
so that was kind of my beginning because
I didn't go to film school I studied
theater so it was a real weirdly for
choosers place to land because the film
unit and now is this sort of machine in
film production where we're producing
films you know from start to finish in
three days every week and and when I
started they were still shooting on film
as well so it was a really amazing you
know place to land and you know suddenly
be unset and so yeah that's why I kind
of went there and then worked my way up
very slowly and yeah and Here I am well
that's fascinating so I guess the lesson
to from that is you never know who
you'll run into you don't exactly be
polite to strangers and yeah I mean
again it was it's there's definitely
moments when I've sort of made a choice
to you know maybe be more aggressive or
two but you know you kind of you do have
to assert yourself and and and you know
I take chances good I don't think you'll
ever have the right amount of experience
that someone's looking for so you know
at SNL for example my sort of my
trajectory sort of follow the pattern
the first few years of me like the SNL
season is like a school yeah yes it goes
September to May and then you have the
summer off you know and you can you know
obviously go to other things or not work
but I usually would go and work on
something else and and and then each you
know September would roll around and
then my first few years I never knew if
I was gonna get hired again the next
season but you know I'd in every a phone
call would come with with Jim and you
know I'd usually sort of just maybe
embellish a little bit about what I'd
done that summer to sort of elevate my
my experience so I quickly sort of went
from being a PA to a production
coordinator the following season and
then and then I was his line producer so
the my third year at SNL I was lime
producing the film unit and completely
fine I might see in my pants I had no
idea what I was doing and it was
weighing over my head but you know week
by week got through it and and then I
did that for about I was I was the line
producer that for about
five or six years before I I made the
move to directing and that's a whole
other thing too I don't think it's
something you google you can only again
I think some people's personalities are
made for it I don't think I was I sort
of managed to do it for all those years
and again for me it was an amazing
learning experience cuz you can you you
know by becoming responsibility for
everybody you inevitably had to learn
about every you know position on set
because you obviously its troubleshoot
at any time anyone had an issue so you
get to know you know the grip department
and their equipment needs and what they
do and the electrician's and the art
department so it was a really good way
just for me to really live my way all
the way around and then the same through
post-production again I just got really
like a sorta landed in this weird film
school as a know and you know it was on
on the job training so yeah what's with
the stress of knowing that you may not
come back exactly that's yeah ya know
exactly so you always kind of again you
never rest on your laurels you so take
everything as I well you know I'm gonna
keep going as far as I can and you know
cuz who knows like I might be looking
for another job soon you know like not
that they encourage an environment of
insecurity but you know it I think it
helps keep moving forward you know not
to get complacent every film at been
associated with has taught me a lot and
by the way and truth be told probably
learned more from the films that didn't
get me thinking back on why they didn't
get made what could I have done
different but the films that got made
which had the ones people know a bit
more hopefully I would say the moth
Mothman Prophecies
which was another Richard Gere film was
and there was one moment one seminal
and again that was a film that that had
been shocked all over town every company
independent medium big studio all passed
on it I wasn't involved at the time the
agent shop didn't the writer I hadn't
produced before I was the I actually got
to produce his first film and he came to
me and said would you read this and I
fell in love with it and his and and
then I learned it had been passed on and
I found there was one company and only
one company that hadn't seen it
that was Lake Shore wonderful company so
I said you know what I will I will
invest time in this and I will take it
to lakeshore and and I knew it was that
was it there was literally one buyer in
the whole world I can sell this to so I
went to them and they read it as three
eggs a q-tips and they called me the
following Monday morning typical Monday
morning call right brilliant story we
loved the craft it was intriguing based
on a true story oh my god fascinating
beautiful beautiful beautiful responses
from all of them at which point one of
them said so thanks so much for sending
it over it's gonna be passed only in
Hollywood and I thought that wait a
minute I'm sorry did you just say it's
gonna be past all this all the hall that
you're you know all this laudatory
language and then you're dead and there
was a long pause cuz I knew this was it
this was the last man standing there was
no other option and that was the company
I mentioned this earlier that was the
company at the moment when I said I
respectfully pass on your past and it
was too nervous laughter I said look of
course you can pass but based on our
relationship and our respect for one
another
I would ask before you make a final
final final decision let me just come in
and talk to you so I I went to this
meeting I told these three executives
the story of my relationship with my dad
why because the script when I read it
initially was so moving to me because
the character played by Richard Gere is
so lost in grief after his beloved young
wife
and a lot of what the texture of it was
reminiscent to me of what I felt after
my dad's death he was my best friend and
and to me this film was a great film in
its own right it deserved to get made
and more importantly it would be a
private amage to my dad and so I care
deeply about it so I went into this
meeting with three people who'd read it
and said nice things about it but passed
on it and so I felt the door was open
just a little bit and I never referenced
the script I never talked about the
title I just simply told the story of my
dad I told who my dad was
I told him about our friendship and her
relationship and and the love that we
had and what it was like when
unexpectedly never having been sick he
just passed away what that was to my
family and to me and I just spent not
long 12 minutes 10 minutes telling this
story at the end of which I simply said
I cannot imagine anyone don't make her
actor audience doesn't matter who will
not be moved or why or whether we lost
someone or not were wired to understand
the tragedy and and despair of losing
someone so close to you and they cuddled
and they changed their mind bottom line
they changed their mind and we got to
make this film and it's a great film it
wasn't as big as pretty woman but but it
was well received in acts I become more
popular over over over the years and I'm
very proud of the film but in a way as a
learning lesson is like you know we
talked earlier about never take no for
an
and I think what I came away from that
was if you are you know if you're ballsy
enough if you're bold and courageous
enough just it's like get naked in
public if you're willing to get naked in
public people are impressed right
because we all know about vibration and
frequency and what if you're like you
know when you're deeply moved and you're
in that very deeply authentic place and
and there's no BS we know it it's real
that's very attractive to us and that's
what we want to put on a big screen and
that's what they got they got why this
is gonna move the audience and Airport
potentially be a success and the film
was successful as a business matter but
I
that's no you know I don't measure it in
those terms I just think how do I get a
yes from these people so I can do what I
so desperately want to do as a creative
person and and the only thing I could do
is tell the truth
and it worked I was broke I had no no no
no money no driver's license I was
living in mid-wilshire I was in a very
bad spot I had been acting now about
five or five years at this point five or
six years I had not had any auditions
for film yet I had only gone to do
things in like the theater things
through the drama-logue backstage West
and whatnot subsequently my friend my
very best friend in the world at that
time was an actor who's become rather
you know prominently known as his name
is Thomas Jane we were very very close
he auditioned wait I got into the
audition now is that is that okay now
okay all right
he again this is a little bit new for me
so ya know so he he he told me you know
I met this I auditioned for this movie
about an
angry skinhead or whatever and there was
this British director and he was very
eccentric and he was in the room and he
didn't seem to respond to my audition he
was referring to the the you know the
director of Tony Kaye who directed
American history acts he said I think
this director would like you I don't
know why he just got that sense that
somehow Tony Kaye was going to connect
with me somehow or respond to me I guess
or my my and my acting or whatever yeah
anyway so that's what life was like that
it was okay to answer your question in
short life was very difficult
broke no car no driver's license no job
and trying to get auditions it was it
was pretty tough yeah so you take Tom's
advice you walk in that door for the
auditions no what happened is is tom
said had there dis this keys in trying
to figure out at that time they had not
confirmed that Edward Norton was you
know playing the lead part in the movie
and he was doing these cattle calls if
they I guess apparently if that did not
happen or what direction they were going
with the lead role I don't know what
they had not figured that out yet
apparently so he said they're gonna do a
cattle call they're gonna be doing these
cattle calls between New York and Los
Angeles and he was doing one there and
then doing one here and it was on this
day and I got the information and he
told me where it was gonna be and he
said you know I haven't had the script
because you know I auditioned and I said
well and he said I'll drop it off at
your house so I was in following morning
I he came in the middle of the night I
was sleeping I lived on the first floor
he put it in between my window and left
it on my TV the top of my TV set and I
woke up in the morning and I went and I
started making my coffee or whatever and
I look and there is a script on the the
top of my television set and it was just
a weird moment where I went I didn't
know what that was and why it was there
it was some kind of like Lord of the
Rings moment or something really we
like I really like it was surreal
because where I was in my life at that
time and what that script wound up
meaning for the totality of my life was
insurmountable I mean because
essentially what ended up transpiring
from reading that story to the audition
to then the relationship that I had with
tony kaye four or five well for many you
know for multiple years working and
since then just keeping in touch here
and there but uh we have had a
relationship that has gone for years as
a result of that I just covered a lot of
ground there really fast I'm loving I'm
assuring this this yes in this apartment
you I'm gonna keep going with that
please I want to know yeah how it all
went down I actually you know I had said
earlier I did not have a job done I
actually had a job answering phones that
was like I got a job way out and like
Santa Monica somewhere it where I had to
get up and take the bus at five o'clock
in the morning for minimum wage to
answer the phone for this Farsi speaking
computer company and I was the only
American speaking but there were
wonderful people and they were very
religious and they were they were
amazing people and this was a you know
you have to understand being 20 24 at
the time with no money absolutely broke
I you know every dollar I made it the
student in this silly little job was
going to every amount of living expense
I had so there was no spare it was just
a difficult time meeting friends to help
me out and whatnot so when this audition
came up I thought this is unbelievable
because so first so let me get back to
the story the first second of reading
that script my I had had a very long
difficult complicated you know childhood
in and out of the juvenile hall systems
and all this kind of stuff my brother's
name is Daniel Danny the when I opened
the script and I had gone through a very
similar cathartic emotional experience
in my life dramatic in nature very much
similar to the dramatic nature of the
spiritual shift in the carrot
in the story so when I read the script
it was overwhelming the emotion that
came over me that was not only what was
going on in my life personally at the
time but also the fact that my brother
and I meant that a lot of stuff after I
became a moved here and found the new
way to live right so it was it was a
powerful experience so I could not wait
for the opportunity to express whatever
you know these feelings were at this
audition so I had no idea what the
audition was going to be so I asked the
Iranian computer the Iranian family that
ran the company if they would allow me
to leave work because I explained to
them you know and I said and I talked
the man he's a very religious man so you
can imagine this was a like you know
with a very long you know with the beard
and the whole thing and I went into his
office and said sir you know if I could
go out do this things I'm an actor I've
been trying to do this he got the woman
that worked there to give me a ride he
permitted me and drove me there when I
get there there's a line going it's a
it's a building on Wilshire Boulevard
near San Vicente in that area over there
where there's a pavilions right nearby
and it was on the it was I believe on
the third floor there's a line going out
the door and everyone is getting a
number and when you walk through the
building you're greeted by the casting
director that says okay listen this is
directors you know he's a little bit you
know does things a little differently
he's got a camera set up up there he's
gonna you're gonna when your number is
called you're gonna walk in front of the
camera and you're going to you're gonna
do whatever you know whatever you do
whatever you I guess whatever you're you
know gonna show Tony or whatever so now
I knew this was going to be
improvisational in nature and I had
already read the script so I knew one
key pivotal point in the story that is
that there was this scene that the lead
character does to the news cameras when
he discovers that his father's been
killed his father was a firefighter and
his father died so the media is
reporting him and he has this huge
emotional outburst
and he's you know he's and he's right
into the camera and he's pointing into
the camera and I knew that was in the
material so what was happening inside of
the audition room was Tony was calling
people up and he would say how do you
feel about white power go and the actor
would start talking you know I this that
the other and cut next and it was going
literally like a firing squad like that
one and of course you can imagine
sitting there aware that you're about to
go up there there's the room it's full
everybody's watching everybody's
audition so you can understand there's a
hundred people in the room and
everybody's watching you get just wiped
out and I said you know I was had
everything nothing to lose I figure you
know anyway he called me up I looked at
him I saw him when he walked in the room
and I thought that's about what I
thought a director looked like real tall
scary bald and intimidating presence
very interesting this man walked into
the room and I thought that's that's a
director I go up and you know I came
from a school and a man that taught
acting that was very very very intense
and he you know he pushed it to the
limit and it was about risk and you put
it all and sort of leave it all on the
field so to speak right and the idea was
that you have to commit all the way all
the way
no no hesitation make your choice and
you go launch no fear you face whatever
fears there and you spring anyway and
take it all the way as far as you can
within your choices so when it was my
turn to be called up I thought I don't
know what's about to happen here but my
heart was pounding very very fast and I
don't know what question he was going to
ask me
I had had an experience the day prior
where I was sitting on the bus and a
young a young a mother and her son were
he was like two and a half and she was I
would say abusing him hitting him and I
had witnessed the whole thing and he
fell and he was crying and he was in
need and she wasn't really helping him
and then the bus came up and I was about
to say something and I didn't and I
wanted to say and I had all of these
feelings about that right so I plugged
into that that feeling from that
experience and I said I'm going to vent
the anger rage whatever if if need be
I'll use that in this in this audition
so Tony walks up and he doesn't look at
me he gets behind the camera and he he's
looking at changing the film thing or
something and my heart was beating and I
was so nervous and I I couldn't and I'll
I just looked at him and I said how you
doing man and he I go and and he looks
up and he goes fine or whatever and he
kind of looks down and I go I cuz I was
this point kind of my nerves were
overwhelming me so I just said and I
don't know how this just got a flew out
of my mouth I just in a real intense
sort of way I said do you have something
that you need to ask me you got and I
knew that got his sort of attention
there because he looked up from the
camera with a real intense look on his
face and he got real excited and he goes
how do you feel about white power and
got all excited and then I I just well I
guess I used all that and I just you
know I did the audition or whatever and
I just went for it and just I guess I
guess it went very well because you know
I mean subsequently everything that
happened after that
changed my life because I went on to
work with him from
point forward I was cast in the movie
well I should tell you the whole story
right the whole of the whole the whole
progression of it right so I'm assuming
you booked the role right there Alex
no no no no what happened was he was
very you know I got very intense the
audition was going very well in the
sense that I connected that emotion to
that anger I had to that mother and the
rage having my own issues with some of
that stuff as a child and putting that
all in that moment I just used that to
talk to imagine that I was talking to
the media reporter that was asking me
about the dead father in the script so I
took the opportunity to make Tony
talking to me being a news reporter as
if I'm doing now the audition here into
the camera because I was talking to the
camera man that my father and and I was
just using that sort of to express the
rage that this movement of neo-nazism or
whatever is coming and were justified
and all this ignorant that I was you
know having to portray and that's how I
did that and then when he kissed kept
filming it and it didn't stop I just had
to keep going I didn't even I at some
point I was I was like it's a what is
this going to stop as I have to keep you
know generating this improvisation so it
was just like I and then he just and I
said he stumbled because he was holding
the tripod and then you're getting you
know he said no no keep going getting
the light getting the light because I
stopped I said you need me they said no
no no get in the light get in the light
and I just kept going and going and then
he said great I got it and I said great
I walked away and he said hey I see said
thank you
and that was I looked at him and I said
you're welcome and I floated out of
there and I did at that point I didn't
care that I had gotten the part or not I
I knew I did something do you understand
I'm saying you think yeah no I know I
knew I did something of which I could be
proud and that is vitally important
especially having ongoing understanding
of how to be an actor in this business
you have to understand the difference
between obtaining the success whether
you book the part and what you actually
can be proud of what you did in the room
are actually two different things the
results will come out of for many
circumstances that are way out of our
hands but that one thing that you can do
which is a performance to be proud of or
an audition to be proud of I felt that
happened and there was a pretty neat
feeling
did you take the bus back to work or did
the people come no I took the bus back
home just really floating I didn't even
get on the bus right away I walked to
the pavilions and I just sat down
because you have to understand at this
point life was beating me right I mean I
I lived in this cubical tiny 300 square
foot apartment I was just got a hold of
that little job I was just I it was just
life was very very challenging at this
particular point you have all of the
insecurities you know my friends had
started to work which I was very happy
about but subsequently you start feeling
those feelings of insecurity of what you
know what what's gonna happen here where
does this go and yeah so it was a very
cathartic it was an unbelievable moment
and then you had to fill out your name
card and this whole thing and I forgot
to write my phone number so I left the
audition and I thought well that's too
bad a week went by and I I didn't hear
anything and I knew something happened
in there and so anyway I had left my
mind my information three weeks has gone
by now and I have heard nothing and now
at this point I let it go but that's
still that sense that I did something
well still remain with me so I wasn't
like disappoint or anything because I
had no real expectations then I get a
phone call from Thomas Jane anyway see
Louie wakes me up and he and he says hey
man
where where what do you do wait wait
what the hell are you doing what are you
doing I said what are you talking about
he said what do you mean what am I
talking about
he's they're calling - trying to find
you you didn't put your phone number on
the audition card you idiot
he said that but they've been trying to
get a hold of you the director really
liked your audition and he wants to
bring you in to read for further role
the lead role at that time I guess they
had not officially signed Edward Norton
or a name actor so I guess that was
still in play for a moment there so it
was an unbelievable moment that phone
call and then like you got to get a
script there you're going in next week
you're going in the directors in New
York he's gonna come in you're going in
to read and it was just crazy cuz I had
never really auditioned for anything I
mean they had to do with the movie I
just at that point just done all plays
so I didn't know what that meant so I
got anyway I got I got to say and I just
worked on a day a ninth day and night
and day and night day and night day and
night and when I went in I went in it
was it was that same scene with the
firemen that they're talking to the news
reporters and it was an extremely III
got there and when I went in to read I
took a breath and and again I was there
I was in the right right you know place
emotionally and it was the audition was
fantastic when well was you know I was
very emotional and then then the Edward
Norton subsequently signs on to the
movie but they got they call now Tom's
manager who's not yet my manager but who
then became my manager after that
audition because you know success has
more fathers and failure has none right
so when you start succeeding suddenly
you start acquiring here that's another
thing you must prepare yourself for -
anyway that's a whole nother
conversation
but keep yourself keep yourself in line
here and keep yourself and your craft
close to your heart and don't weigh your
value upon the light whether others
approve of you must be proud of who you
are and your work to survive in this
business I believe in the long term
anyway moving forward so you booked the
role that's no so I did the audition
then then they said hey Edward signed on
as a movie Edward Norton signed on in
this movie the I had I wasn't in SAG yet
I had done nothing nothing no credits
zero so this was all for me like a dream
or something you understand it was like
I said what meaning being in this
process at this point for me was
unbelievable
like a dream who was coming true you
know from nothing literally nothing I
can't even get on a bus on time to now
I'm in a studio auditioning for a role
it was overwhelmingly amazing feeling
and yeah so I did that and then they
said they really really responded she
signed me as a client
so she orchestrated then the next
callback which they said they're
bringing you back in so actually now I
had someone to talk to about acting it
was really bizarre I went from nothing
to now I have like a manager and like
whoa this is really weird
right it was really weird um so then I
went then I went two weeks later I I
went I to Stacy Keach is part I had
auditioned they were auditioning me for
that I walk in the room and this was
definitively for my whole entire career
will be the defining most joyous moment
that I have ever experienced in my whole
artistic life was that moment when I
went to the final callback to do the
scene that Stacy Keach does with Edward
Norton in the
at his house there after Edward Norton's
come out of prison or whatever in the
movie no so I was being such a intense
young actor that acting was everything I
was so prepared and so involved in that
final callback because I knew that I was
very very close to being having my first
opportunity to be a professional actor
if you will you know that this was an
opportunity and it was close and I had
so as an intense actor and I was so
nervous that when they called my name I
had on a trench coat I was dressed like
the character I had my combat boots on
my green skinhead trench coat you know
my wife beater I was working out every
single day
and I couldn't handle the idea of
walking in the room and talking because
I knew I wasn't gonna be able to do that
I wasn't gonna be able to walk in there
and just start chit-chatting and then
get into it I was too too there if you
will so what ends up happening is I
storm in the room now looking back in
hindsight it was a bit theatrical but
how do people know how they process it
really but I I storm I walk in the room
and I declare and I start taking off my
trench coat and I look to the casting
director and I said Who am I reading
with tell me who I'm reading with come
on I want you to tell me right now who
I'm worried who-who am i reading with
and my hand is shaking a little like
that and and she immediately gets very
serious it says yeah you ready with him
you leave he'll be taking an audition I
said okay are you ready you ready okay
you guys ready and and I just took over
this sort of all being driven by my
terror obviously my absolute fear but no
it was amazing and and then and then
yeah and then they taped it I put my
feet up on the
on the desk and began the scene and then
yeah and then it went really well and
when it was over I felt like I had done
what I needed to do like whatever it
happened I trusted I breathed and I
allowed that audition to sort of flow
and I I I flip over my I flip my paper
like that and I said huh that's that's
that and they said great job Alex
although all the people tend to be a
great job great job
I said great great thank you John
Morrissey or the one of the two
producers I forgot the other one's name
how terrible of me one of those two
gentlemen that produced the movie one of
them said looks to me and says do you
have a girlfriend I said no no I don't
have a girlfriend and I was still you
have to understanding with the character
and just had done the audition he says
well do you have any friends and I said
yeah yeah I've got it got a lot of
friends and my friend had actually
driven me to the audition so I could
focus and he said well he said why don't
you go now you gotta understand the
backdrop to this I had had five years of
it had been very difficult so he looks
he looks at me and he says well why
don't you go call your friends tonight
because we're putting you in this movie
and if there is a moment in life where
you you you feel some kind of
unbelievable
good fortune or a dream come true I
guess would be the word considering the
the amount of uphill fight it is to
become an actor right to have that
moment for anyone and I don't think that
ever changes for any actor as long as
they go I think every time you get that
you got that part there is just nothing
better and more gratifying than that
moment and yeah it was pretty incredible